[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
discours public spécial présidentiel
nous abordons chaque semaine un thème de
campagne une préoccupation majeure des
français la semaine dernière nous avons
parlé sécurité aujourd'hui nous allons
parler santé et nous recevons car ils
lacombe bonsoir karine lacombe merci
beaucoup d'être là merci professeur vous
êtes on rappelle chef du service
hospitalier des maladies infectieuses de
l'hôpital saint-antoine à paris vous
avez été un des visages de la crise qu
vides il y a deux ans presque jour pour
jour le virus provoqué la stupeur en
france partout en europe et dans le
monde et le premier confinement vous les
soignants étiez aussi saisi mais à la
différence de nous vous étiez en
première ligne est complètement débordé
aujourd'hui karine lacombe 14 mars 2022
nous tombons les masques et le pass
vaccinale n'est plus réclamés
qu'exceptionnellement c'est une étape
importante pour les français est ce que
c'est un risque important pour vous du
point de vue épidémique vous allez nous
dire que nous a pris par ailleurs cette
crise de notre système de santé comment
va l'hôpital quelle réforme est-elle
nécessaire que demandez vous aux
candidats à la présidentielle puisqu'on
est en pleine campagne et surtout que
doivent-ils réalisé de votre point de
vue vous nous le dire dans un quart
d'heure brigitte briller bouche et
autres admis vous poseront ces questions
pour le figaro albert et nous débriefera
votre interview et nous joindrons
vincent roux dans l'intervalle il y a
deux ans je le disais karine lacombe le
virus écraser tous et arrêter tous
finalement sauf entre autres l'hôpital
d'abord quand on évoque cette période
extrêmement particulière quelle image
vous revient d'abord à l'esprit en
mémoire de cette époque
je dirais que le l'image qui me revient
immédiatement
à l'esprit c'est ce fameux week-end
juste avant le 14 mars 2020 12 13 mars
2020 où on est mon attendait depuis
quinze jours l'arrivée de la vague
épidémique comme on la voyait en italie
et on a on s'est préparé on avait fait
des réunions de préparation comme on
allait s'organiser et quand la vague est
arrivée qui n'était pas une vague
tsunami on s'est rendu compte dans les
heures qui ont suivi que tout le travail
de préparation qu'on avait fait mais
n'était pas du tout à la hauteur de ce
qu'ils nous frapper et il a fallu dans
les heures qui ont suivi les jours qui
sont arrivés qu'on ce qu'on se
renouvellent qu'on innove et que tous
les jours on change de mode de
fonctionnement et alors vous parler de
comment le
l'une des leçons qu qu'on peut tirer
c'est la façon dont on a dû s'adapter et
la preuve de l'adaptabilité qu'on a
montré dans le système public
l'hospitalisation privée qui a rejoint
assez rapidement le système public et
l'effort considérable que chacun d'entre
nous avons dû faire et justement à
l'épreuve de cette capacité d'adaptation
c'est vrai que les soignants sont
devenus des héros rappelez vous
on vous applaudissait sur les balcons
c'est bien en tant pardon pour
l'expression mais c'était assez dingue
quand même ce qu'on a fait à l'époque
est-ce que depuis près de vous qu'ils
soient fils de chef de service
d'infirmières etc certains ont craqué
ils sont partis faire autre chose
alors oui bien sûr alors il ya plusieurs
raisons donc effectivement il ya déjà un
épuisement de comme si quand vous avez
quand vous devez faire face à un danger
imminent vous faites face vous êtes vous
êtes grands devant le danger et vous
arriver finalement à
maîtriser le danger et puis quand le
danger disparaît vous sentez vide est
vidé de l'intérieur vidé
émotionnellement vidé de vos ressources
physiques vos ressources psychiques et
certains d'entre nous on se sont dit moi
je vais aller souffler je vais faire
autre chose et il y en a
vraiment autre chose il y a 2 bal des
oui du personnel beaucoup de
d'infirmiers et infirmières aides
soignants aide soignante qui se sont
engagés dans des procédures de
reconversion alors beaucoup je ne sais
pas en fait je ne sais pas le chiffre
mais moi j'ai des exemples ponctuelle de
personnes qui sont allés voir ailleurs
qui se sont sont dits non moi l'hôpital
maintenant c'est bon pour moi je vais
voir ailleurs donc soit qui sont restés
dans la profession soit pour certains va
qui ont changé d'orientation alors entre
la photo que vous avez vous aviez à
l'époque de l'hôpital en mars 2020 et
aujourd'hui vous nous direz tout à
l'heure ce qui a changé et ce qu'il doit
encore changer mais je voudrais qu'on
fasse un point de la situation
épidémique donc aujourd'hui 14 mars 2022
d'abord dans votre service ou à
saint-antoine est ce qu'il ya des
malades covin alors si on parle de mon
service proprement dit nous n'avons plus
de malades qu'ovide nous faisons
quelques sorties de réanimation mais
nous n'avons plus de malades de lakovic
19 comme on l'a connu il ya deux ans ou
même il ya quelques mois avec la vague
delta avec la vague au micro on a
vraiment un profil de passion
complètement différent on a
essentiellement des personnes
immunodéprimées qui ont été vaccinés
mais chez lesquels le vaccin n'a pas
marché comme non pas de défense
immunitaire qui leur permettent de
répondre à la vaccination
et donc elle présente des formes covin
assez pas pas du tout la forme classique
plutôt
de la fièvre une décompensation des
maladies sous jacentes donc pas du tout
ce qu'on a pu connaître un d'accord mais
ce que me dit c'est que ce que vous
voyez venir encore à l'hôpital ce sont
les immuno déprimées par exemple qui
sont encore touchés et les personnes
très laide jerson très âgées et c'est ce
qui explique le petit rebond de
d'hospitalisation de 3% c'est ce qui
pourrait expliquer alors pour l'instant
on n'a pas encore de description très
pressés parce que ce petit rebond est
très récent donc il faut quand même un
petit peu de temps pour qu'on collecte
les données qu'on observe ce qu'il se
passe et qu'on puisse décrire et publiés
mais ce que l'on voit actuellement en
hospitalisation
ce sont vraiment ces personnes yeux
déprimés qui ne répondent pas la
vaccination des personnes âgées qui
n'ont pas non plus répondu à la
vaccination ou qui ont été
incomplètement vaccinés et est-ce qu'on
a encore des personnes non vaccinées qui
arrive avec une forme classique très
probablement mais ça reste très à la
marge alors ce qu'on voit aussi et on va
regarder le schéma il est passé mais en
fait c'est le schéma des contaminations
vrai qu'on garde un petit peu vous me
voyez peut-être pas mais vous le
connaissez par coeur ces derniers jours
le niveau de contamination reprend
légèrement à la hausse et ma question
est simple on a enlevé le masque ce
matin on ne demande que le pass thaksin
al dans un certain nombre de lieux où il
était exigé est-ce que c'est trop tôt
car il me lacombe
je pense qu'il n'est jamais trop tôt
trop tard je pense que quand on prend
une décision telle que celle de ce matin
où on enlève les gestes barrière dans la
plupart des situations on le prend dans
un ensemble avec un avec avec un
faisceau de avec un faisceau d'indicés
et un
faisceau de et surtout des situations
une situation actuelle qui est très
différente de ce que l'on avait il ya
plusieurs mois on a maintenant une
couverture vaccinale qui est quand même
extrêmement élevé parmi les personnes
qui ne sont pas vaccinés beaucoup ont
été contaminées ont fait des formes
modérés ont des anticorps on a
maintenant des traitements
des traitements par voie orale qu'on
peut donner pour les personnes qui ont
des risques dans des formes graves quand
elles vont voir leur médecin traitant on
a maintenant d'autres traitements qu'on
peut donner chez les personnes
immunodéprimées pour les protéger on a
également des traitements que l'on donne
à l'hôpital quand on a de l'inflammation
donc on a quand même un des outils qu'on
en a suffisamment exactement qu'on
allait nous permettre d'affronter
absolue heureusement
pour être simple le masque on peu lent
vers le droit vous nous dites oui vous
pouvez l'enlever je pense que oui on
peut l'enlever
ce n'est pas une obligation il faut que
les personnes qui se sont à risque ont
le droit de continuer de leur ballon et
ça c'est interdit l'euro reperd ce n'est
pas interdit de le porter mais vous
savez on il ya aussi une incitation
collective dans certaines situations
vous dit non mais on va stigmatiser
maintenant les personnes qui souhaitent
garder le masque non c'est tout à fait
râler moins rêver doit faut pas venir on
l'avait bien la peur de quoi bienvenue
dans exactement chacun est libre de 7 de
cette décision la portée ou pas porter
le masque dans les espaces ou six
autorisées après il y à des endroits où
il est obligatoire de porter le masque
les transports en coin je pense que ça
c'est très important les aéroports les
gares pourquoi on passe ce sont les
établissements hospitaliers les et les
établissements hospitaliers semble
indispensable c'est indispensable de
continuer pourquoi en l'instant à porter
le masque parce que ce sont des endroits
où cohabitent des personnes qui viennent
de différents horizons où on ne peut pas
forcément retrouver les personnes avec
qui on a été en contact et que bako
compte si vous avez été en contact avec
quelqu'un de malade qui vous connais
vous allez vous testez vous allez mettre
en place des mesures barrières pour ne
pas transmettre alors que dans les dents
les circonstances de transport en commun
et c'est pas possible alors vous nous
dites
il ya déjà des lieux vous les avez
d'ailleurs listé où on doit porter le
masque encore de façon obligatoire
est-ce que vous professeur lacombe pour
nous dit il ya d'autres lieux où je vous
recommande aussi de le garder quand même
même si c'est pas encore c'est pas
obligatoire je pense que pour l'instant
justement parce que on doit faire preuve
d'adaptabilité qu'on voit qu'on a une
légère reprise des contaminations tous
les endroits où on est dans des espaces
fermés où on peut être en contact avec
des personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés
et 11 dans un attentat lors par exemple
on est cinq dans un ascenseur cinq ou
six vous dit vous avez pensé plus tôt
c'est plutôt dans des endroits où on va
rester longtemps sans sans ventilation
donc ça c'est très important le
renouvellement de l'air
c'est vrai que l'une des leçons qu'on
doit retenir de cette crise sanitaire
c'est la transmissibilité par l'air donc
non plus par les grosses gouttelettes
mais par l'aérosol isation et donc qu'on
ait une meilleure hygiène de l'air
intérieur et ça c'est pas forcément
quelque chose qu'on savait appliquée en
france donc une des leçons à retenir
c'est que quand on est dans un endroit
clos on reste longtemps avec des
personnes d'horizons divers où on ne
peut pas avoir de renouvellement de
l'air il faut porter le masque une
pensée qu'on s'est un peu aviez teese
est un c'est pas du tout péjoratif mais
est-ce qu'on a un peu capture asiatique
du masque ou non finalement il faudrait
qu'au relais naturel français et latin
va revenir au galop il faudrait qu'on
les cons les cons les intégrer quand on
va se retrouver dans des situations de
bouffées épidémiques mais pas seul ça
pas simplement de vivre ont fait et bien
par exemple pour tout ce qui concerne la
grippe les gastro entérites et c'est
quand on est dans des situations
d'épidémie d'infections transmises par
l'air donc là où il faudrait que l'on
reprenne a l'habitude de porter
exactement de se laver les mains et de
porter le mal ça c'est le souhait du
professeur lacombe asco penser que c'est
un peu entraînant dans notre dans nos
réflexes on va voir on va voir ledez
l'avenir bien sûr quand on va retrouver
retourner dans les périodes hivernales
que là on est au printemps donc on voit
bien que on commence à faire beau r on
ouvre les fenêtres et c'est vraiment le
test de savoir si on a appris ça va être
à l'automne on voyait le schéma tout à
l'heure une petite reprise des
contaminations + 3 % des
hospitalisations sur une semaine
glissante je crois
on peut parler d'une nouvelle vague ou
pas c'est trop tôt pour le dire on a
quand même ce fameux sous variant au
micron ba2 qui est beaucoup plus
transmissible que le b1 qui lui même
était plus transmissible le delta tout
en perdant quand même une part de sa
virulence c'est à dire sa capacité à
donner des formes graves dont 11 jeunes
thons peux pas dire maintenant qu'on est
au début d'une nouvelle épidémie parce
que enfin d'une nouvelle vague parce que
la transmissibilité d'un virus à partir
du moment où ça ne donne pas de forme
grave hospitalisation en réanimation
c'est pas non plus extrêmement
inquiétant parce que on n'est plus du
tout dans le contexte de ce qu'on a
connu auparavant le professeur lacombe
nos dit qu'on n'est pas pour l'instant
dans une nouvelle vague c'est important
dans un instant brigitte et âmes vont
poser des questions vont élargir un tout
petit peu le débat avant qu'on les
retrouve 70 % des français estiment que
les questions de santé
malgré tout ce qu'on a vécu depuis deux
ans sont insuffisamment traités pendant
cette campagne présidentielle est ce que
c'est votre avis alors il y à des
mesures dans les programmes de chacun
des candidats mais en revanche
l'expression le fait de porter la santé
comme une des préoccupations majeures
non plus des votants et des candidats
oui je suis entièrement d'accord avec le
ressenti des français on parle on parle
finalement très peu de très peu de santé
et surtout les candidats qui veulent
parler de santé souvent sont occultés
par des priorités qui sont portées par
des candidats les plus médiatiques
questions de sécurité intérieure je
parle
c'est on voit bien que finalement ça a
pris le dessus alors ce qu'on a vécu
depuis deux ans c'est quand même d'un
événement m'ont dit le majeur qui a mis
notre pays à l'arrêt et qui est un
problème de santé problème de santé
publique sans faire face aux épidémies
aux nouveaux enjeux ses lecteurs pour
les années à venir c'est une occasion
manquée ça vous choque c'est le jeune
victime ans apprennent si peu de place
oui c'est vrai que c'est julien contexte
de guerre qui écrase alors là tout c'est
une autre guerre et les tragiques elle
est en europe on comprend mais même
avant qu'il n'y ait la guerre ces
questions de santé était passé pas sous
le tapis mais elle devenait presque
secondaire elles sont devenues
secondaires pour beaucoup de candidats
et elles ont surtout été occultée quand
certains candidats ont essayé de
remettre sur le devant de la scène les
questions de santé donc je trouve que
c'est dommage et maintenant c'est
maintenant c'est trop tard de toute
façon bon l'élection va bientôt arriver
et puis maintenant le débat est occultée
par une autre menace qui n'a rien à voir
avec ce qu'on a vécu est tout aussi
inquiétant mais quand même en voit bien
que les questions de santé sont en tout
cas la question du corps vide reste
entière un des cas une déclaration ne
serait ce qu'un tout petit peu alarmiste
les français sentent que la menace est
quand même encore très présente et on va
avoir l'occasion d'en parler avec vous
on va rejoindre tout de suite vincent
roux en direct des fins cadets figaro
bonsoir vincent
bienvenus vous avez une question qui
vous a frappé parce qu'elle a aussi
frappé les électeurs du fuyard alive à
karine lacombe oui bonsoir karine
lacombe alors on est on estime selon les
chiffres de la direction générale de la
santé
qu'il y a eu à peu près 16 mille
soignants qui ont été suspendues
parce qu'ils ont refusé de se plier aux
obligations vaccinales est ce que
maintenant que le pass vaccinale est
suspendue est ce que vous soyez
favorable à leur réintégration
alors attention le pass vaccinale est
suspendu pour les citoyens mais
l'obligation vaccinale persiste pour les
soignants et il faut arrêter de faire du
co vide une exceptionnalité il y à
d'autres vaccins qui sont obligatoires
pour les soignants on n'en parle pas si
un soignant ne veut pas se plier à
l'obligation de vaccins par exemple
contre l'hépatite b il ne peut pas
exercer un métier et de soins au contact
du malade c'est la même chose avec le co
vide donc je pense que le la règle est
là elle est applicable pour tous les
soignants et et la levée du pad
vaccinale ne
n'enlève pas l'obligation de vaccins
pour les soignants sachant que ils se
sont vaccinés pour les autres vaccins
qui sont obligatoires
et vu la situation dans laquelle se
trouve l'hôpital la situation très
problématique
dramatiques en termes de personnel est
ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut s'offrir entre
guillemets le luxe de suspendre 16000
personnes moi je retourne la question
aux soignants qui ne se sont pas
vaccinés eux qui ont fait un métier de
contact d'empathie où ils sont là pour
soigner les autres quand on voit la
situation pénurie dans laquelle on est à
l'hôpital pourquoi ne pas faire ce geste
de santé publique de deux de se vacciner
pour pouvoir protéger les autres d'une
éventuelle transmission du coc vide donc
je pense que il faut regarder aussi de
l'autre côté et et comprendre que le
travail que l'on fait est un travail où
on est tourné vers l'autre un travail d'
empathie on est là pour soigner les
autres pour conclure les passants ils
ont ils ont été tournés vers les autres
ils ont été applaudis ont
consenti eux mais eux aussi des efforts
héroïques pendant les vagues de
contamination et pourquoi ne se
vaccinent t-il pas alors on va pas
refaire le débat de la vaccination des
soignants ce soir mais c'était très
intéressant vous répondez à cette
question d'un second questions très
pertinentes eu réellement parce que ça
n'allait pas de soi les choses 20 valent
mieux quand elles sont dites merci
beaucoup vincent bonne soirée
toujours présente brigitte boucher est
en train de nuit et qui vont maintenant
vous revenir avec vous sur la situation
à l'hôpital et l'épidémie demain soir
karine lacombe le premier ministre a
annoncé hier une quatrième doses pour
les personnes de plus de 80 ans et des
immunodéprimés elle est uniquement
recommandée est ce que pour vous il
faudra la rendre obligatoire
je pense que les personnes âgées alors
je peux apporter une petite nuance la
très grosse majorité des personnes âgées
qui se sont vaccinés trois doses ont
bien conscience que si on leur a demandé
de se vacciner c'est parce que la
réponse à la vaccination diminue avec
l'âge à cause d'une moins bonne
efficacité des défenses immunitaires
enfin de la réponse des défenses
immunitaires à la vaccination donc les
cette quatrième dose elle n'est pas
rendue obligatoire elle est conseillée
par ce con parce qu'on sait que la
plupart d'entre eux vont admettre cette
quatrième dose pour améliorer leur en
voulait encourager fortement les
encourage fortement est-ce qu'il faut la
rendre obligatoire
je ne suis pas sûr que ça augmenterait
de façon considérable accès à cette
quatrième dos vous voyez c'est tout le
temps porté à porter le appuyer une
mesure aussi importante avec
le degré de de persuasion qu'on peut y
mettre vous parliez tout à l'heure de
personnes immunodéprimées qui était
pourtant en réanimation aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça sert à quelque chose de
vacciner les immunodéprimés du coup une
certaine partie des personnes me déprime
et répondent à la vaccination donc il
faut les vacciner une dose de doses
trois doses beaucoup ont été vaccinés
avec une quatrième dose mais
malheureusement une certaine partie ne
répondent pas la vaccination donc cela
non seulement il faut les vacciner pour
la partie d'entre eux qui vont répondre
à la vaccination puis les autres il faut
surtout améliorer et élargir l'accès aux
anticorps monoclonaux sachant que pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore des
anticorps monoclonaux qui sont
parfaitement efficace sur le nouveau
micro particules et le béa 2 mais on y
travaille sur le plan de recherche alors
cette quatrième dose donc c'est pour les
80 ans et plus et pour les
immunodéprimés est-ce que selon vous il
faudrait l'étendre au reste de la
population pour l'instant l'état actuel
des connaissances non c'est à dire qu'on
n'a pas montré que une quatrième dose
généralisée dans la population elle est
vraiment permettre
d'améliorer l'état sanitaire ce qui ce
qui améliore la actuellement l'état
sanitaire c'est vraiment mettre l'effort
sur la vaccination mais également
l'accès aux traitements protecteur pour
les plus fragiles qui sont personnes
âgées et milo déprimé et qui sont ceux
que l'on trouve actuellement à l'hôpital
alors aujourd'hui on a à peu près 20% de
la population qui n'a pas un schéma
vaccinal complet aujourd'hui on enlève
le masque
il n'y a plus de passes de passes
sanitaire ou de passes vaccinale qu'est
ce que vous leur dites à ces gens là est
ce qu'ils sont à risque
vous savez dans une décision de santé
publique on a un oeil on l'a bien vu ces
deux dernières années puisque c'est tout
le temps la balance qu'il a fallu qu'on
fasse entre les impératifs sanitaires
les impératifs économiques les
impératifs sociaux psychologiques etc et
donc c'est vraiment un un équilibre
entre toutes ses composantes alors ce
que je dirais maintenant c'est que la
situation sanitaire est quand même
relativement encourageante et que à
partir du moment où on est vacciné que
l'on continue d'appliquer des mesures
barrières je vous parle du mouvement des
personnes
continuent d'appliquer les mesures
barrières pour les plus fragiles parce
que parmi ces 20 % qui ne sont pas
vaccinés certaines ont des risques de
faire des formes graves l es doivent
condamner à garder la main et monuments
qu'elle même se protègent porte le
masque dit qu elle se lave les mains
d'un risque aujourd'hui on a le béa 2
qui est le variant ah oui elles prennent
ariès quel bien sûr et très contagieuse
nombre à barrer en plus voilà parmi ces
groupes les vacciner elle raccordant la
douleur faire parmi ces 20 % ce qui
celles qui ont des questions des
facteurs de risque de faire des formes
graves évidemment elles prennent un
risque bien sûr elles prennent un risque
même réel qu'il ya deux ans dans le fond
alors
probablement que le variant au micron a
une forme à une forme d'expression donne
des formes cliniques qui sont un peu
différents de ce qu'on avait il ya deux
ans frais pour les personnes le taux de
vaccination compris pour les personnes
vierge de toute vaccination mais on ne
peut pas prédire si elles vont faire une
forme grave ou pas donc c'est un risque
qu'elles prennent un risque qu'elles
prennent en connaissance de cause que
depuis deux ans c'est ce que donne le
covin oui vous l'avez dit dans ce que
vous qualifiez pas encore de vagues oui
peut-être un petit rebond il ya la part
du virus b a deux qui est quand même
importante comment est-ce qu'on peut
caractériser ce virus vous l'avez dit il
est plus contagieux il est moins
dangereux en quoi il est
structurellement moins dangereux alors
il est il est donc c'est un virus qui
est beaucoup plus transmissible on voit
dans la souche originel donc là mikron
encore alors que le delta que parce que
la souche au micron est probablement le
béa 2 est un peu plus transmissible le
béa de un peu plus transmissible que le
béa 1 c'est pour ça qu'il prend le
dessus maintenant et au micro ondes et
nettement plus transmissible que toutes
les souches virales qu'on a eues
auparavant plaint du manque de données
s'est fait mener le micro pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée si on est dans
une population qui n'est pas vacciné qui
n'a pas d'anticorps une personne
affectée pente ont affecté 10 autres
alors que la souche originel ou ranel en
affecter deux à trois et delta six à
sept dont vous voyez qu'on monte et le
béa le berriane l'anc dlb à deux c'est
de cesser 12 à peu près ou alors donné
12 ça c'est de 1 à 12 absolument tour
micron c'est de 10 à 12 ans voilà on est
dans la famille on est dans la famille
au micron dangerosité mois mais il
dangereux alors ensuite est-ce que le
béa 2 ou même le bien en gros lui au
micro et moins dangereux que le delta ou
autre c'est difficile à dire parce qu'on
n'a plus de population entièrement naïve
de d'anticorps qui ne sont pas vaccinés
ou qui n'ont jamais été infectées quand
on est vaccinés ou qu'on a été un jour
affectées on a des défenses immunitaires
de différents types qui font que quand
on serait un fake dans la plupart des
cas ont fait des formes qui sont moins
graves donc c'est très difficile de dire
que ce variant la et moins gras on peut
les souris sa naissance vaccination
d'accord la chine est en train de re
confiné il y a dix sept millions de
personnes qui sont en train d'être
confiné à shenzhen là c'est qu'elle
variant qui est concerné c'est au micro
encore une fois donc c'est la vague ou
micron qui qui touche l'asie un peu plus
tard que nous voyez on a à peu près 1 à
2 mois de décalage et et c'est
effectivement dans une population qui
est très peu vaccinés ou quand elle a
été vaccinée c'est principalement avec
le sinovac qui a une efficacité qui est
moins bonne en a même vaccin chinois qui
a une efficacité qui est moins bonne que
les vaccins qu'on a utilisé ce difficile
dans finement pour vous en chine par
rapport à la politique qu'il ya chez
nous alors c'est un peu différent c'est
que le sud est asiatique depuis le début
a pris une option de 0 covin c'est
l'option qu'on aurait voulu prendre
initialement et puis pour beaucoup de
raisons qui n'a pas été applicables en
europe donc c'est aussi lié à ce à
plusieurs facteurs ils vont ils veulent
le zéro coville ils sont très peu
vaccinés et
la maison c'était un mauvais choix 0
comme un dépôt de vaccination pour la
peau la chine vous voulez relire les
pays qui ont fait qu'ils ont alors la
chine a levé le zéro co vide à partir du
moment où ils ont été où ils ont eu plus
de 60 % de couverture vaccinale donc
voilà ils ont ils ont ils ont avancé
d'avoir été vacciné pragmatique la chine
pour l'instant ce n'est pas le cas alors
est ce que c'est un mauvais choix je ne
sais pas je sais c'est une disons que
c'est l'option qu'ils ont prise vous ne
parlez de deux variantes a l'impression
qu'ils sont ou même de moins en moins
dangereux en tout cas compte tenu de la
couverture vaccinale et c est ce que
vous guetter l'arrivée aussi un
invariant qui pourrait être plus
agressif bon on n'est pas où on est pas
à l'abri on ne sait pas ce que l'avenir
nous réserve on ne sait pas ce que
l'avenir nous réserve c'est possible
c'est possible bien sûr mort que
généralement les modèles trouver plus
rapidement là pour l'instant on est
toujours sur le b à deux ça fait un mois
donc c'est quand même nom c'est très
rapide on a eu le delta je vous rappelle
que le delta a émergé en juin l'année
dernière et nous on a eu quand même deux
vagues successives et puis au micron a
immergé en janvier fin décembre janvier
on est juste au début du mois de mars on
est mi mars le bea de est là depuis un
mois en gros donc on peut c'est quand
même c'est quand même assez fier
car on est toujours alors ça c'est les
virologues c'est la surveillance
épidémiologique des souches virales qui
pourra nous le dire ci invariants émerge
alors après on a beaucoup de variantes
qui émergent mais qui n'ont pas de
traduction en termes de l'infection
antenne en même pas 2 vireux notre
tournoi ou alors on parle de façon
anecdotique on surveille on voit que ça
prend pas le dessus et puis voilà mais
ça veut dire que l'hypothèse d'un
nouveau confinement comme il ya deux ans
elle n'est pas totalement exclu non non
je ne pense pas qu'on ira vers un
nouveau confinement parce que on a
vraiment un
dans une boîte à outils qui c'est
extrêmement enrichissant n'est plus du
tout dans la situation d'il ya deux ans
on comprend mieux malal on comprend
mieux la maladie on comprend mieux le
virus on a les vaccins on peut s'adapter
très vite en termes de composantes de
vaccins donc nous on n'est pas du tout
dans la situation parliez tout à l'heure
d'une éventuelle recrudescence à
l'arrivée de l'hiver est ce que vous
pensez qu'à ce moment là il faudra se
faire se faire vacciner et est-ce qu'il
va falloir se faire vacciner tous les
ans un peu comme la grippe en france
alors vous savez que la grippe le vaccin
est recommandé pour les personnes
vulnérables en gros les personnes
vulnérables et le personnel soignant
peut-être que pour le sarko v2 ce sera
la même chose
les personnes les personnes fragiles
particulier à gmail déprimé et le
personnel soignant on va voir ce qu'il
en est dans les mois à venir mais
probablement qu'on irait plutôt vers une
une situation de ce type là avec
peut-être des vaccins combinés
d'ailleurs et l'industrie développe
d'ailleurs des vaccins combinés qu'ovide
convient de grippe on va rentrer russe
l'association va paraître l'hôpital tam
oui le ségur de la santé a permis de
pardon ce qui apparaît clairement c'est
que c'est être vaccinés empêche pas
d'attraper le coc vide est ce que pour
les prochains vaccins c'est là dessus
qu'il faut travailler c'est sur la
transmission du virus pour vous ben on
aimerait même vous allez me voir c'est
bien sûr on aimerait pouvoir et couper
la transmission du virus alors les
vaccin est assez efficace sur les ans
sienne souche les souches sur lesquelles
elles ont été développées parce que les
vaccins avec la souche lujan la souche
alpha et delta diminue la transmission
elle la diminue également sur au micro
mais beaucoup beaucoup moins qu'avec les
souches plus anciennes donc oui
effectivement ce serait là ce serait ça
pourrait être un des critères de
développement d'un vaccin un autre sujet
ce sont les co vide long
est-ce qu'il y en a encore il y en a eu
beaucoup aujourd'hui en france des
copies de long il y en a eu donc vous
savez que c'est une entité qui est très
discutée où on cherche un
substratum physiopathologiques pour
expliquer les symptômes données dures
alors un substratum c'est qu'est ce
qu'il ya dessous qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce
qui explique on fait un coup vie de long
il y en a du mal à le qualifier aussi ce
camp-là renault on sait pas trop où on
en a conscience du mal on a on a du mal
à savoir exactement l'origine du coc
vide long quels symptômes peuvent être
traitées et est-ce qu'on peut prévenir
le coville long et donc c'est vraiment
un champ de recherche qui est en pleine
expansion et coup pour vous c'est comme
ils l'ont ils sont avérés ils ont été
vraiment une ils ont une existence ils
sont on les dit assez
fatigué c'est ce que c'est
psychosomatique que ça il y as
probablement des cas qui relèvent plutôt
de mécanismes psychologiques mais il y a
très probablement des cas qui relèvent
de vrais mécanismes physiopathologiques
qu'on a besoin d'élucider et on peut
avoir des séquelles à vie avec un kobe
de long on peut avoir des séquelles à
vie alors à vous ça va ça brûle encore
mes deux parents dans tout cas des
séquelles à deux ans c'est sûr on a des
personnes qui ont fait des vrais cow
vide et qui ont des séquelles à long
terme et on a des personnes dont on n'a
pas pu vraiment prouvé le coc vide et
qui ont des séquelles avec des examens
qui sont anormaux et donc on a besoin de
mettre un peu d'ordre là dedans et c'est
pour ça que c'est un champ d'exploration
en termes de recherche qui est important
alors 91% des français selon un sondage
de l'ifop estime que la priorité pour
réparer l'hôpital c'est de répondre à la
pénurie de soignants est-ce qu'ils ont
raison selon vous a bien sûr un fax lui
ment de toute façon indépendamment du
coc vite ça fait plusieurs années que
l'on que que l'on que l'on lancent des
cris d' alerte en termes de déserts
médicaux et quand on parle de déserts
médicaux s'est pas uniquement dans les
régions rurales où on a plus de médecins
les voiles au total tous les jours vous
le vivez certains l'hôpital c'est en
médecine ambulatoire à paris par exemple
alors qu'on était une grande métropole
il est extrêmement difficile de trouver
un médecin généraliste qui accepte de
vous prendre dévoue à la vitesse par
exemple nous allons finale est aussi ce
besoin on n'a aucun cas un énorme besoin
de personnel paramédical
parce que le métier n'est plus attractif
pour beaucoup de raisons en particulier
salariales en particulier de
reconnaissance de statut en particulier
de valorisation de sens que l'on donne à
notre métier et des conditions de
travail et on a un vrai problème de
recrutement de personnel paramédical
évidemment les infirmiers infirmières
aides-soignants aides soignants mais
aussi toutes les professions de support
les kinés etc etc les assistantes
sociales on est en pleine pénurie des
sciences sociales sans assistantes
sociales on n'arrive pas à travailler à
l'hôpital alors olivier ferrand a
annoncé du renfort 1000 lits de
réanimation
est ce que c'est bien pour vous est ce
que c'est vraiment une goutte d'eau ça
ne va pas suffi alors c'est très
important c'est bien d'avoir plus de
lits de réanimation
est ce que c'est la solution d'avoir des
lits de réanimation pérenne sachant que
l'activité de ranimation est très
fluctuante dans l'année et que en dehors
de périodes de période épidémique on
n'est pas toujours en situation de
tension ce qui est important c'est que
ces l'hydre animations puisse être en
période creuse reconverti dans une autre
type d'activité donc pas franchement la
ranimation lourde mais des soins
critiques qui nécessitent plus la
surveillance continue donc ça c'est
important mais ça ne suffit pas on a
besoin d'eux de renforcer beaucoup de
lits de gériatrie par exemple on a
besoin de renforcer les services
d'urgence et on a besoin surtout aussi
d'une articulation avec la ville parce
que c'est aussi parce qu'il est de la
pénurie en médecine de ville en médecine
ambulatoire qu'on la médecine
ambulatoire c'est tout ce qui n'est pas
le spécialisation qu'on a cette
saturation des urgences et de l'autre
côté un problème d'aval mais si on avait
plus de lier ce qu'on aurait du
personnel soignant pour s'en occuper
est-ce que c'est pas un problème de
formation c'est aussi un problème de
formation par exemple en termes de
médecins si on a des déserts médicaux en
termes purement de couverture médicale
c'est parce qu'on a eu pendant des
années un numerus clausus qui était
beaucoup trop ce train j'en avais qu'on
n'a pas on en a eu c'est marrant pendant
des années on a pensé que le
dés le déficit des dépenses de santé
l'augmentation par don important des
dépenses de son art est rendue au nom un
troc une trop grande offre médicale une
erreur de diagnostic en vente diminue
l'offre médicale on va diminuer les
dépenses de santé mais c'est totalement
aberrant c'est totalement aberrant et on
est dans des impasses comme celle qu'ont
à laquelle on alors il a délibéré et un
numerus clausus ça leur pari les
desserrer oui donc là il est desserré
mais c'est cet art c'est à dire qu'on va
avoir et on l'a expérimenté ces
dernières années on en a encore pour
plusieurs années dans le former les
médecins seront de creux le temps de
former les médecins bien sûr donc on
essaie de pallier on essaie de pallier
ce déficit par exemple en facilitant
l'accès à l'eau
des praticiens étrangers à la médecine
en france 2 qu'elle tomberait donc une
audition aujourd'hui pour faire venir
pour rendre un très grave eric hélary
bien sûr france on arrive à faire venir
des médecins étrangers ah oui on arrive
mais on est dans des statuts qui sont
complètement sous valorisées et pour
lesquelles on se bat également pour
qu'ils aient une meilleure
reconnaissance des parts que ça venait
ariste justement à cause de ce sous
traitement de statutaire amis absolument
qu'on vous regardez par exemple dans les
pays anglo saxons mais ils ont des
conditions les médecins étrangers en des
conditions d'accueil qui sont beaucoup
plus favorables que chez nous je teins
jumelage en aura même un problème de
pénurie de salaire pour faire venir des
reins des médecins étrangers à baba déjà
par exemple
donc là on parle des mécènes étrangers
mais parler par exemple uniquement des
infirmiers infirmières dans les pays
anglo saxons pour celles d'entre elles
qui parle france qui parle anglais ou
encore par exemple au canada on leur
offre des conditions de travail et de
salaires qui sont bien meilleurs que les
nôtres et cambodgiens meilleur c'est pas
du simple au double c cool mais les
partitions travail les conditions de
travail c'est à dire qu'en france une
infirmière doit s'occuper de 12 à 15
patients en médecine conventionnelle
au canada c'est 6 à 7 ça alors là c'est
salaire égal demandé à la firme hier où
elle préfère aller travailler amri
justement on va parler un petit peu de
seuil et réponses qui ont été apportées
d'abord par le gouvernement avec le
ségur de la santé il a quand même permis
de revaloriser la rémunération de
nombreux soignants les infirmiers les
aides soignants il a même été étendue à
des métiers oubliés du médico social ces
dernières semaines est ce que c'est pour
vous suffisant on vous répondre à cette
interrogation c'est important parce que
ça représente et pour certaines
infirmières 10 % d'augmentation
donc c'est important ce n'est pas du
tout négligeable et ce à un effort de la
société de l'état parce que l'état c'est
non c'est nous qui avons aussi fait
globalement cet effort salué ses patins
je salue cet effort mais c'est
insuffisant âge où ces invalidations non
c'est un rattrapage c'est un rattrapage
mais c'est pas suffisant il faut aller
au delà il faut augmenter le recrutement
donc on en entend beaucoup de chiffres
puisque là on est en période
préélectorale on va on va embaucher 15
mille vingt mille soignants plus c'est
tout oui c'est important parce qu'on a
bien vu que ce qui nous a manqué pendant
sept pendant cette pandémie ça a été le
personnel soignant et heureusement qu'à
la première vague on n'a été que deux
régions majorel majoritairement touché
l'île de france et le grand test
imaginez que toute la france étaient
touchées de façon aussi importante que
l'île de france et le grand est mais on
n'aurait pas fait face parce que si on a
pu faire face c'est parce que tous nos
collègues de province sont venus nous
aider dont il faisait des réalités et
ses les leçons à tirer de cette pandémie
vous avez comparé à l'instant la manière
d'exercer son métier en france et au
canada justement qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait améliorer en france pour vous à
quel ratio il faudrait arriver entre les
soignants et les patients qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour que les
journées à l'hôpital soit à longueau
soit plus attractive pour leurs
soignants il faut que alors il ya
beaucoup de l'amélioration des
conditions de travail de notre personnel
en particulier paramédical est
extrêmement important il faut qu'il y
ait moins qu'il y ait un ratio malades
soignants alors moi je parle infirmiers
infirmières beaucoup plus faible c'est à
dire qu'il faudrait pas dépasser 8 à 9 à
la limite disnat combien aujourd'hui ben
ça alors ça dépend dans quelle structure
mais ça peut monter jusqu'à 15 est en
fait qu on vous a vu les fermières une
infirmière dernier patience patience
voilà et quand vous êtes à une
infirmière pour 15 patients un aide
soignant pour 15 patients ben vous
pouvez pas apporter le soin la qualité
de soins qu'on attend qu'on devrait
attendre 2 2
l'hôpital big ça vous semble un déjà un
effort is made in une amélioration dans
le traitement des chèques oui oui comme
hermès vient après tout dépend aussi de
la lourdeur des soins je veux dire on
quand on a un un service où ça tourne
vite où les patients restent trois
quatre jours ils partent par rapport à
service de gériatrie par exemple où les
soins sont extrêmement lourds ou un
service de neurologie avec des personnes
très très handicapée accidents
vasculaires cérébraux etc c'est pas
pareil donc il faut aussi mettre en lien
ce la lourdeur du soin avec le avec le
nombre de personnels pour changer ses
règles à ce que pour vous il faut mettre
plus de médecins va mettre des médecins
dans la gouvernance des hôpitaux
oui c'est essentiel bien sûr et
d'ailleurs on a vu là pendant la crise
sanitaire on a travaillé main dans la
main avec avec le personnel
administratif les directeurs d'hôpitaux
etc ça s'est extrêmement bien passé
parce que toutes les décisions ont été
prises ensemble et toutes les décisions
étaient prises par rapport à la réalité
de terrain et c'est ça que l'on essaie
de faire remonter il faut que les
décisions soient prises localement en
fonction des réalités de terrain or pour
l'instant je sais tout ces dernières
années c'est le poids de
l'administration a été a été très fort
mais le sait pas le directeur d'hôpital
lui même on a bien vu que tout le monde
est de très bonne composantes et cherche
à faire du mieux possible mais quand les
ordres viennent d'en haut de diminuer
les dépenses hospitalières et qu' on est
là directeur d'hôpital appliquer des
politiques qui viennent d'en haut et qui
sont des politiques qui sont là pour
gérer la pénurie ça peut pas bien se
passer alors il ya la gouvernance et
puis il ya la gestion le gouvernement ne
vous veut mettre fin à la tarification à
l'acte est ce que c'est une méthode qui
vous semblent inadaptés vous au
fonctionnement de l'hôpital
en fait la tarification à l'acte c'est
une bonne méthode quand on fait des
soins type chirurgicaux les soins
chirurgicaux mais quand on est à
l'hôpital public où on s'occupe de
patients très défavorisé deux personnes
très âgées qui peuvent rester très
longtemps à l'hôpital parce qu'il n'y a
pas deux structure d'havas l'adapter
quand on doit prendre des personnes en
charge des personnes avec des maladies
chroniques très lourde on voit que ce
n'est pas adapté s'est pas adapté parce
que nous on nous dit vous savez la
tarification à l'acte des avis une
pathologie en gros c'est huit jours pour
la prendre en charge si votre passion
reste 15 jours vous êtes pénalisé mais
s'il reste 15 jours ce n'est pas parce
qu'on se tourne les pouces et parce que
il présente on n'a pas de lits d'aval
pour qu'il puisse faire une
convalescence satisfaisante c'est un
patient qui n'a pas de moyens pour qu'on
puisse le faire retourner à domicile etc
donc c'est beaucoup de composants que
l'hôpital pu alors ok l'hôpital public
doit faire face et et la tarification à
l'acte ne répond pas assez contre
saint-louis finalement au fonctionnement
de l'hôpital ah bah oui ça nuit au
fonctionnement d'un hôpital par cette
étape il faut changer de système
complètement même jeté le bébé non gelée
je pense qu'il faut adapter il faut
avoir un système mixte qui prennent en
charge fakih qui prennent en compte les
contraintes à system système hospitalier
mais là on parle beaucoup de l'hôpital
mais il ya aussi toute une réforme de la
médecine ambulatoire à faire également
johnny va enchaîner maintenant qui est
enclenchée mais il faut qu'on aille plus
loin dans en deux mots comment bien en
deux mots par exemple essayez de enfin
résoudre ce problème de pénurie médicale
ça c'est la base même de la démographie
une pénurie médicale pour que l'hôpital
ne se retrouvent pas submerger avec des
avec des urgences qui saturent et une
dégradation de la qualité de vie à
l'hôpital il a quelques minutes pour
parler d'un sujet qui nous tient à coeur
c'est les ehpad oui on a beaucoup parlé
de la maltraitance dans les ehpad a
notamment avec les révélations du livre
les faits swire de victor castanet est
ce que ces révélations elle vous on vous
étonner
elle nous le dire que non non non non
non non elle ne m'ont pas étonné alors
après on a là on a eu vraiment des
exemples très très très précis et très
très difficile comme ça qui ça passe ça
vous a pas étonné par ce que nous avons
entendu ces histoires oui on a des gens
te disent histoire et puis surtout on
voit arriver à l'hôpital n'arrive à
l'hôpital ce genre de choses non non
voit on voit les personnes des ehpad
excusez moi on voit les personnes des
ehpad arrivée à l'hôpital et est parfois
dans des
conditions extrêmes en maltraitance qui
a pu être dénoncés
ah ben on a des exemples de maltraitance
et on avait des personnes arrivées d pad
un décès bien sûr on a déjà fait des
signes à l'avant et cetera bien sûr bien
sûr dont une dernière question on est
dans un contexte de guerre un bien sûr
la guerre contre l'ukraine on a fermé
dans ce contexte des médias qui sont
jugés propagandistes dangereux est ce
que vous auriez souhaité qu'on fasse de
même avec des médias qui ont été
propagateurs de fausses informations
pendant la pandémie
ça c'est
en fait on a on est
c'est vrai qu'on est toujours en france
on défend la liberté d'expression ça
c'est extrêmement important en revanche
on ne peut ne peut pas défendre la
liberté de désinformer et c'est vraiment
ce que ce dont on a manqué pendant ces
deux ans c'est-à-dire d'organismes de
contrôle
officiel qui lutte contre la
désinformation
ce n'est pas normal que ce soient des
citoyens qui doivent se constituer en
comité en association pour lutter contre
la désinformation et on hamm est laid on
a manqué de se contrôler plus officiel
de lutte contre la désinformation c'est
clair et derrière médias que vous visez
en particulier pour vous qui ont
vraiment
des médias oui enfin des médias en
particulier beaucoup de deux médias qui
n'ont pris de médias que le nom en
particulier sur le web où il ya moins de
où il ya moins de vous il ya moins de
filtres en faire un livre -
oui j'ai quitté les réseaux sociaux puis
après je me suis dit après tout si on
parle moins et pia 7e un ami parce que
j'étais parce qu'à un moment j'ai
vraiment été envahi par ce qu'ils
pouvaient se déverser comme le n par le
par les réseaux sociaux
après oui on sait sur les sur les
réseaux sociaux il ya moins de contrôle
ça c'est évident même si on dit que les
laits que les réseaux sociaux doit faire
2 de la modération on voit bien qu'on
arrive à passer de tout modéré bien sûr
bien sûr non moi je pense qu'il ya eu
déjà des personnes à qui on a donné
énormément de visibilité parce que parce
que c'était des bons clients pour le
professeur les médias non mais je vais
pas donner de noms parce qu'il est
question n'a pas qu'un seul mais c'est
aussi c'est aussi tout un système
derrière et c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il
faut démonter que et oui la lutte contre
la désinformation devrait être une des
priorités
d'un ministère qui s'occupe des médias
ces diplômes merci beaucoup merci
brigitte merci dame on va évidemment
accueillir dans un instant à berzé nous
une question puisqu'on l'a abordé un peu
en filigrane c'est la question des
déserts médicaux est ce que vous seriez
vous favorable à la coercition c'est que
les médecins ne veulent pas d'obligation
d'installation ils défendent absolument
le caractère libéral de leurs
installations est-ce que vous voyant ce
qui se passe le subissant vous dit pas
s'il faudra en passer par là alors c'est
vrai que je ne suis pas complètement
neutre je suis moi-même
fonctionnaires-salariés donc
je je
[Musique]
c'est vrai que j'ai un point de vue je
ne dirais pas qu'il faut de la
coercition mais il faudrait vraiment de
fortes incitations et moi ça ne me
trouverai pas illogique dans un état
dans un contexte de pénurie que quand on
a de jeunes praticiens qui viennent de
finir leurs études comme ça se fait dans
énormément de pays que pendant trois
quatre cinq ans
ce soit un service rendu à la nation
quand il a été
installé dans des structures alors pas
forcément au libéral complet parce que
c'est très compliqué d'être dans une
zone rurale en libéral complet mais
qu'il y ait des maisons médicales où ils
puissent avoir des conditions d'exercice
satisfaisante mais que pendant quatre
cinq ans il s'engage à aller dans des
endroits où où on manque de médecins moi
je pense que j'ai toujours été favorable
à ce type de à ce type d'incitation et
ça se passe dans de nombreux pays alors
je sais que beaucoup de collègues qui
exercent en médecine libérale vont vont
être peut être choqué par ça m'est passé
par troyes s'aimer mais vous vous dites
waouh france à rennes par là alors
est-ce qu'il faudra en passer par là en
tout cas c'est une option dont il faut
discuter et il faut dialoguer et essayer
de trouver des compromis sur ce terrain
là oui en tout cas c'est un sujet de la
campagne présidentielle quand on saute
quand il y aura plus de pénurie parce
qu'on formera beaucoup de médecins
peut-être que ce sera on pourra
retourner à une activité beaucoup plus
libérale oui la médecine est un peu
imposé cette obligation à titre
provisoire jusqu'à ce que la population
médicale soit suffisante par exemple
soigner les français bonsoir albert zeh
nous merci d'être avec nous rédacteur en
chef du service politique du figaro vous
avez écouté karine lacombe avec beaucoup
d'intérêt en plus avec bono puisque nous
avait dit que la cinquième vague allez
sans doute pas venir un truc que vous
avez un discours très positif est-ce que
par ailleurs puisque aujourd'hui on fête
la fin du fin à la suspension du passé
actional et la fin du port du masque lee
est-ce qu'ils ont été possibles de de
faire ça avant on sait que dans d'autres
pays je pense à l'angleterre ou s'agit
ni
ces mesures de restrictions ont été
levées
plutôt que nous est ce que l'on était
possible en angleterre ils ont été aussi
touché plus tôt que nous par la
cinquième vague donc on avait à peu près
un mois de décalage donc c'est pas non
plus illogique que ayant été touché plus
tôt que nous ils décident de lever les
mesures plutôt que nous
non je pense que pourquoi les avoir levé
plus tôt je pense que tout ce que l'on
gagne en termes de consolidation de la
maîtrise épidémique la couverture
vaccinale etc c'est toujours ça de gagné
et donc ce ce cette envie de s'ouvrir et
d'aller vers plus de liberté elle et
elle et elle est commune à tout le monde
est ce que aujourd'hui encore je reviens
sur ce message positif on peut on peut
sortir sans problème être dans les lieux
publics allez par exemple moi dans mon
journal aujourd'hui il y avait encore
quelques personnes qui portaient le
masque donc mais le trim mais donc c'est
il n'y a plus aucun problème pas la
liberté de porter le masque comme je le
disais tout à l'heure il est très
important de la garder pas stigmatiser
celui qui va porter le masque en disant
oui la peur etc il peut avoir des
conditions personnels de santé qui fait
qu'ils estiment avoir besoin de se
protéger et ce n'est pas parce que il
n'est plus recommandé de porter le
masque qu'il est obligatoire de
l'enlever alors faire attention à ça
ensuite ce qui est c'est important de
saisir cette liberté est déjà de montrer
que non on n'est pas dans une dictature
sanitaires ou parce que on a préconisé
le masque pendant longtemps ça devient
quelque chose d'état bidon on ne sent
pas donc ça c'est aussi important de
comprendre que quand la situation
sanitaire est favorable on peut lever
les gestes barrières et la situation
sanitaire les parce que on à la
vaccination on a les traitements on
rentre aussi dans le printemps on sait
que les conditions météorologiques sont
plus favorables je reviens sur une chose
que vous avez thèmes que vous allez
aborder sur les déserts médicaux qui ne
touche pas seulement les zones rurales
telles qu'on pouvait le port pour y
croit mais également des grandes
métropoles y compris paris
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui explique
quand le problème des arbitres ou ça
fait des années qu'on en parle fait des
années que les gouvernements successifs
essaye de s'atteler au à résoudre le
problème il n'y arrive pas pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'y arrive pas eh
bien en fait on n'y arrive pas parce
qu'il ya eu la conjugaison de deux
facteurs principaux
d'abord un grand nombre de médecins qui
sont arrivées à l'âge de la retraite
donc ils sont partis et en même temps un
numerus clausus 13 trains gens qui n'a
pas formé autant de médecins que deux
médecins qui partis à la retraite est
l'une des raisons principales c'est
qu'on s'est dit beaucoup de dépenses de
santé on va restreindre l'offre et ça
fera baisser le recours aux soins ce qui
était une aberration puisque la
population vieillit la population qui
vieillit et plus qu morbide on a des
nouveaux traitements innovants etc les
gens vivent plus longtemps ils sont plus
malades en quoi c'est un peu le serpent
qui se mord la queue et on a pas on n'a
pas apporté une réponse on n'a pas assez
anticipé
ce fait de ce fait de société là et donc
voilà les déserts médicaux se sont
installés après pour répondre un désert
médical 1 1
médecin ça me disant être formés c'est
une 10 15 ans à terme et donc des
politiques oui c'est une erreur à un peu
des deux faces est comme puisque la
dette des deux je pense des deux des
neuf pays des défilés de médecins dans
la rue sauf erreur qui disaient non vous
vous trompez complètement vous allez
voir dans dix ans on va payer le numéro
ce panneau il ya eu ce moment là il ya
eu il ya eu beaucoup de manifestations
alors book c'est beaucoup mais les
manifestations sont beaucoup partie de
l'hôpital public donc évidemment
l'hôpital public à manifester pour les
urgences et tout mais enfin il y neuf
sont pleins mais moment où les
politiques prenaient des décisions qui
ont engagé effectivement des
conséquences terribles pour l'hôpital et
on se souvient pas d'une protestation
majeur du corps médical à ce moment là
il était assez facile je veux dire non à
risque avec ces chaleurs que les
politiques peut-être c'est non non non
non non alors déjà de toute façon le
milieu médical est pas un milieu médical
qui descend facilement dans la rue pour
manifester franchement des mains face à
nîmes à sa liberté voilà une image mais
mais mais le mercantour n'at il y a eu
il y a eu beaucoup non ici non il faut
pas croire il ya ce que ya pas mal
d'alert qui ont été lancés je parle sur
le contrôle d'un berger nous et beaucoup
de ministres de la santé qui étaient eux
mêmes médecins et qui ont pris c'est
d'essayer l'essentiel on peut le dire
est ce que le ja il ya deux thèmes qui
qui qui sont ressortis de cette campagne
qui est presque finir c'est à la fois le
thème de la santé le thème de
l'immigration la sécurité de la fin tous
les cas d'immigration et là on vient
avec sur le thème de des médecins
étrangers est ce que est ce que c'est un
des moyens efficaces de pallier le
problème du manque de personnel est ce
qu'on pourra toujours s qu'il faudra
toujours avoir recours à des médecins
étrangers
évidemment quand on est dans un dans un
système de pénurie faire appel à la main
d'oeuvre étrangère est quand même un des
moyens très rapide de pouvoir pallier le
manque de personnel donc oui et on a
beaucoup de collègues étrangers qui sont
très bien formés et et qui peine à avoir
un statut au regard de leurs compétences
à avoir un salaire au regard de leurs
compétences même si les choses
s'améliorent petit à petit et c'est
évident que c'est une que c'est une des
voies de pour répondre à un problème
très rapidement mais évidemment il ne
faut pas se baser uniquement sur l'appel
d'air des médecins étrangers alors
pourquoi c'est parce que c'est aussi une
chose à laquelle on ne pense pas c'est
condren des ressources humaines qui sont
formés dans un pays et qui va perdre ses
ressources humaines au profit d'un pays
occidental donc ça aussi on voit que
c'est pas un système qui est pérenne il
faut que chez nous on forme plus de
médecins plus de personnels soignants
infirmiers etc est ce que est ce que
l'objectif de former plus de médecins et
réaliste est ce que les moyens sont en
revanche en regard des besoins dès que
vous formulez activement il faudra dix
ans pour que aujourd'hui l'étudiant en
médecine qui rentre en première année
sortent diplômés est ce que est ce que
l'hôpital est ce que l'université
française est en mesure de former plus
de médecins alors oui ça me dit c'est
une excellente question à ce que les
universités françaises sont en capacité
d'accueil est en capacité de formation
alors il ya un potentiel d'ajustement
puisqu'on on a quand même ces dernières
années déjà augmenté le numerus clausus
si on devait encore plus l'augmenter
alors est en fait là on peut l'abolir
également et et faire en sorte que ce
soit que ya un numerus à perthus
d'ailleurs locale régionale qui permet
de fixer la formation du nombre de
médecins dont on a besoin donc ce
numerus à perthus lui nécessite qu on
augmente les capacités d'accueil des
facs et part ça ça c'est en discussion
assez déjà cessé des gens courent mais
c'est sûr qu'il faut que se sont
amplifiées donc on voit que c'est toute
une chaîne qu'il faut refondre mais pour
reprendre pour rebondir sur cette
excellente question pour les candidats
qui disent on veut la fin du numerus
clausus sylla décrétait 25 avril au
matin au lendemain du deuxième tour est
ce que l'université française aurait les
moyens d'accueillir tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont candidats la réponse
toute façon non mais mais en même temps
comme dans tout comme dans toutes
filières il ya tout de même une
sélection à faire parce que on veut
former des des professionnels qui vont
pouvoir faire face à toutes ces années
d'études et qui ont les qualifications
pour pouvoir s'engager dans une autre
ville américaine traite comme ça va
forcément y aurait de la section a trop
forte a pendant de très nombreuses
années bien sûr et je pense qu'on a
perdu des jeunes des jeunes qui avaient
vraiment la vocation à être médecins et
parce qu'ils ont eu à faire un concours
extrêmement sélectif pas toujours sur
les bons critères de sélections
d'ailleurs on s'est privé de bons
professionnels les choses changent on a
quand même fait une réforme profonde du
premier cycle des études médicales voilà
je pense qu'il faut continuer à aller
dans ce sens la dernière question albert
pour vous et avec eux sur la coercition
justement l'un des moyens de lutter
contre
cette coercition de forcer des médecins
plutôt libéraux allaient à laisser
aller s'installer dans des dans des
déserts médicaux est ce que c'est une
réponse plus politique ou sanitaire est
ce que pense une réponse sanitaire
moi je nomme je pense que c'est une
réponse sanitaire alors après ce que ça
doit passer par la coercition sauf que
c'est dû à la coercition je pense qu'il
faut qu'il y ait qu il y ait des qu'il y
ait des discussions il faut qu'il y ait
des incitations fortes pour que pour
pour qu on pour que des jeunes médecins
ou même moins jeunes mais pas aux
médecins notamment bien alors c'est sûr
oui souvent des décisions qui ont été
prises avant et oui mais vous savez la
mentalité change parce que une bonne
partie qui veulent continuer à
s'installer en libéral mais beaucoup
souhaitent également plutôt s'installer
dans des activités salariées dans le cas
de maisons de santé ou l'organisation
des soins peut être peut se faire en
bonne intelligence avec le maintien
d'une vie de famille de qualité et dont
vous voyez les choses les choses
changent il faut accompagner ce
mouvement
merci beaucoup merci karina content
d'avoir été avec nous en amour ça vous a
soudé l'hôpital la crise
ça nous a soudés je dirais que oui ça
nous a
ça nous a fait travailler en
collaboration avec tout le personnel
administratif qu'on avait plus qu on
n'avait pas sonné avant voilà c'était
beaucoup plus cloisonnés ans travaillait
beaucoup plus son silo et j'aimerais
qu'on garde cet esprit oui c'est
important parce que la qualité de la
qualité de vie à l'hôpital elle passe
aussi par là par le par le bonheur qu'on
a d'aller travailler et de faire
correctement notre métier dans des
bonnes conditions c'est une donnée
france pour finir un sel l'émission le
bonheur d'aller travailler merci
beaucoup qu'un acompte de remanier merci
beaucoup albert et nous nous avoir
d'avoir conclu cette émission ensemble
on se retrouve bien sûr pour audition
publique la semaine prochaine à 19h30
sur lcp et public sénat bonne soirée à
vous
[Musique]